- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Are you moving to New York?
- We are moving to New York.
- I love that.
- So we're very excited. Yeah.
(Vin claps aggressively)
(crowd claps and cheers)
I love- Yeah! (Kelly claps)
- Come on, bro.
- Come on bro, let it up.
Come on. Come on.
(crowd cheers and applauds)
Let it up.
(Kelly laughs)
That's a New York love, guys!
(Vin claps)
- We are very excited!
- Come on guys!
(Kelly giggles)
- That's a New York love.
- I know I love, and I, and even, even so
for my kids, like growing up here,
there's a lot of culture.
- Yes.
- Growing up in New York, there's a lot.
So either way, they get,
that's a win for them.
- You're gonna love New York.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Every time I'm there,
I love it.
- [Vin] Okay. Okay.
- You know why I walk around everywhere?
- Yes.
- No one walks here.
- Yeah. You sit in your
car for four hours.
- [Vin] That's such a good point.
- Yeah.
- [Vin] I was telling my kids, I said,
because we live in LA most of the time,
and you realize
that your kids haven't really developed
their swag walk yet.
(crowd laughs)
And the reason is,
when you grow up in New York City,
one of the first things you have to do
as a little kid, is learn your swag walk.
(Kelly laughs)
- Gotta start working on mine.
- There's a swag walk.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- That's the thing you
need when you're growing
up in New York City.
You have to swag walk
to the train station,
you have to swag walk
through the subway cars.
- What is your swag walk?
'Cause like, I feel like
when you look like you,
you just walk.
- Aww.
(crowd gushes)
- Yeah.
Like, I feel like people like me,
we need to work on something.
- Aww. (crowd giggles)
- But like, you just walk in
and like, everyone's like, he cool.
He's fun.
- [Vin] Aww.
- [Kelly] Like, you know.
Yeah. What is your walk?
I wish I could see it
as you as a young you.
- A young me?
- [Kelly] Yeah, a young you.
- Okay. I'll give you a young you.
- [Kelly] Give me young.
You can do it, thespian.
(Kelly giggles and claps)
(crowd cheers and claps)
(Kelly laughs) Oh my god, I'm so excited.
(Vin grunts)
(Kelly laughs) Pump it up!
Pump it up! (she laughs and claps)
(Vin grunts and laughs)
Pump it up! Pump it up!
- Okay, this is, this
is the real young me.
This is when I didn't have any money.
(Kelly guffaws)
(crowd laughs)
(Kelly claps and crowd sympathizes)
- See?
- [Vin] Or, after I would
do my break dancing session,
I'd take off my hat, and I'd go,
"Yes, credit cards are accepted!"
(Kelly and crowd laugh and clap)